all right well i'm talking today
with dr james lindsey
dr peter bogoshian and dr helen
pluckrose
and they're all
famous or infamous depending on your
perspective
as the authors of a series of hoax
articles that were published in what
purport to be academic journals
in the last year
following up work done by sokol back how
long ago was that
no it's got to be like 25 years now
right right so we've all assumed or
you've all assumed that the situation
hasn't approved so the first thing i'm
going to do we're going to have an
extended discussion about these articles
and about the motivation for producing
them and the necessity for that and the
morality of that and the aftermath and
all of that and the first thing i'm
going to do is have each of you
introduce yourself and then we'll launch
right into a discussion about uh
let's call it the scandal
dr lindsay
yeah um
good to be here so
i have a background in mathematics and
physics my phd's in math i left academia
in 2010 and have been studying uh mostly
religious
and moral philosophy and psychology
since and
then got wrapped up in this idea i kind
of was the i guess epicenter of the
project i did all the submissions and
managed all the emails and all of that
and then peter and ellen
uh
filled in all of my weaknesses and so we
spent you know in 18 about 18 months
working on this a year really 10 months
writing papers
then there's the getting ready to go
public so
um
that's kind of who i am and how i got
into this i just a
lapsed mathematician who gives
a lot of concern to
how we produce knowledge and what what
academic standards are and should be so
what why did you leave academia
i wish i could say that it was like this
prescient thing i saw the writing on the
wall that it was going mad and i wanted
out but really it was just a number of
personal responsibilities and
commitments that led me to not want to
pursue
um employment where i didn't know where
i would be placed from you know one
postdoc to the next it was family
commitments primarily
but you were still interested enough to
continue well with this project interest
enough in the academic world
yeah i never really
wanted to stop researching or reading
and thinking and coming up with new
ideas it's very difficult to do
mathematics without some institutional
backing
math is hard as some people have noticed
so i didn't have the resources necessary
really to pursue
mathematical research independently but
i found that i could
you know dig into philosophy and i could
dig into
uh psychology kind of on my own not
professionally of course but um enough
to get an idea of what i was was looking
at in a philosophical sense to answer
questions that i was
really deeply interested in mostly the
question that drove me probably from
about 2011
forward was
you know what do people really mean what
are they talking about when they say the
word god and so i really got involved in
talking about the thinking about
religion that's what led me to religious
and moral psychology trying to
understand why people
believe things that they do and why they
why they manifest their beliefs in
certain ways and
ultimately because i was you know that
kind of a guy i just wanted to find out
what the i figure i live in the
southeast u.s it's a really religious
area people talk to me about their
belief in god all the time i hear it
constantly at different levels
from the
you know yeah there's i i kind of
believe level all the way to the
borderline insane
level of conviction
to very implausible propositions level
and i wanted to understand i know the
people talking about ideas like god mean
something when they say the term it's
something very not just do they mean
something they mean something very
important to themselves and i wanted to
figure out from a perspective that
didn't rely upon
the religious the theology or the
religious mythology or narrative
what they were speaking to as articles
within in the material world
and so i became very interested in that
and spent a number of years reading and
writing about it
and by
the way the kind of culture war if you
want to call it that progressed and
seeing what was happening to people i
was interested in um sam harris for
example was was certainly one of these
people
you see these people get called racist
or sexist for what seemed to be nothing
and you try to dig into it again with
the interest and meaning of words
kept seeing these references back to
these you know power dynamics and um
sociological definitions that that only
see racism or sexism as structural
entities that allow
basically people of
people to be considered racist or sexist
just because of their identity
by just by virtue of being say a white
male you could be racist and sexist oh
you inevitably are that's the exactly
exactly so
that's what led me to get curious about
the the grievance studies canon
ultimately i see okay peter
let's hear let's hear from you tell
everybody who you are and what you're up
to
um i'm currently teaching philosophy at
portland state university in the
philosophy department and
i am up to james lindsey and i just
finished a book i have impossible
conversations that will come out
probably in 2019 from decapo press
and i don't know what i'm up to now
because i may be
looking at a career change very soon
so um
we will get into that later but the
university filed charges against me they
found me guilty of not seeking irb
approval and um investigation is ongoing
for the falsification
we better have quite a conversation as
well about irb approval that's another
rabbit hole we can plunge down because
that's another catastrophic catastrophe
that the university has has inflicted
upon itself over the last two decades so
that's something that's become
increasingly politicized
so it's very difficult to understand how
you could get irb approval for a satire
or why you might need it
okay okay good helen let's hear from you
well i'm i'm the member of the group who
isn't doctor i'm i'm a lonely ma but i
have a background in literature and
early um i said late medieval early
modern studies i've i'm interested in
how
women used the the christian narrative
to um
to get authority and autonomy for
themselves for the 1300 to 1700 so i'm
looking at how this changed before and
after the reformation how the narratives
changed
but i um i left at the end of my masters
i was intending to go back and do my phd
in medieval manuscripts
but it's just got
i keep going earlier and earlier because
it is so difficult to get away from the
ideology i'm i'm interested in medieval
manuscripts but not overwhelmingly i
want to look at social history but it's
so difficult to do that because there is
a pressure now to do so
anachronistically to read it through
gender ideology of today so i have to
accept that the reason i was going to do
medieval manuscripts is because i can
translate and transcribe and this is
something objective that i can do i can
produce an addition
of texts which aren't readily available
and explain them and that's the only
real way that i'm able to look at
religious writing by and about
women and in the objective way and it
isn't really i want to do so i stepped
away for a year and in that year i
started writing about
about post-modernism about feminism
about liberalism and ideology and then
there just got to be so much to do with
that
that i i haven't gone back at all so
involved in in writing about what's
going on right now
and so that that is where i'm now
i see well it's interesting because you
you talked about
your
your belief that women in the
mid stages of development of the
christian church were using the ideas to
actually liberate themselves and to
yeah yeah i'm little for example from
marjorie kemp to emilia lanier and um
we're looking at very different ways
in which you know within the catholic
narrative for example women would say
well god speaks directly to me he is
the old
patriarch this gives me a certain
authority to disagree with a patriarchal
if i think it's fair with my husband and
then later after the reformation there
was a slightly different emphasis in
which
women you know everyone could interpret
the bible and that includes women so
there was a different kind of authority
there too so that that's generally been
what what i've been interested in the
slightly different ways that women have
approached biblical texts biblical
narratives
and um and and yes and used them to to
challenge sort of mainstream
interpretations and um and make some
make some pretty good arguments well
emilia lanier certainly did marjorie
kemp mostly screamed
okay so
why don't we start by uh
why are you guys telling us what the
genesis of this project was let's
outline the project itself that the
sequence of papers that you wrote
and let's talk about the genesis of that
as well so
i want you to take that one yeah okay
it's really kind of kind of interesting
i don't know if your audience would know
this jordan or not but all three of us
you know were writing a bit within what
might have been considered the new
atheist vein and working within that and
then i was working on a book trying to
answer my big
kind of early 2010s research question
what do people mean
when they say god i was writing a book
called that i eventually titled
everybody is wrong about god
and uh peter called me one day while i
was working on either the book itself or
the research for it i don't recall the
specifics at the time
but he called me one day and said you
know dude dude i think i'm going crazy i
keep trying to tell people something
that's as obvious as can be to me
and
somebody has to believe i'm not crazy
everybody thinks i'm nuts please tell me
i'm not crazy and so i said you know
what is it and he said
um
i look at the way
people in gender studies use their
scholarly canon the way they they
produce that the way that they refer to
it
the the fact that it seems disconnected
uh in a literal sense from what's going
on in reality
and it feels like it's their bible it
feels like it's a holy scripture for
something like a religion am i going
nuts and as it turned out the reason i
started writing the book
everybody's wrong about god was partly
to answer my big research question but
it was also because i noticed that the
community built up around new atheist
activism which called itself the atheism
community
showed almost all of the symptoms of
qualifying as a religion at least from
like durkheim's perspective and maybe
even from some others
so i i immediately latched onto what
pete said and i said no you're not crazy
i think you're probably right i think
you are absolutely right that the
scholarly canon in gender studies and so
on
is operating like
a book of faith for something but i
don't know exactly what this is and so
we got curious about that scholarly
canon kind of from that point it wasn't
long after that
that the infamous feminist glaciology
paper came out uh where the
a few four or five researchers published
a very well-funded study showing they're
claiming to show that glaciology is
inherently sexist all the way back to
its roots
um
back to you know the
intrepid explorers of mountains and
polar regions and all this so it is
justified by being a big tough guy in
the 19th century or whatever and
that apparently somehow this masculinist
bias hangs over and so the answer to
this is to put feminist art projects as
part of glacier science and indigenous
mythologies as part of glacier science
or else it's racist and sexist
and
i i mean i remember reading the paper
lightly at the time and thinking there's
no way this is real and peter and i had
a phone call we started looking at new
peer review on the twitter at the same
time oh you should never look at that
oh my gosh
okay so look so we've we've actually got
two issues here then let's say now all
of a sudden because
yeah there's a there's the there's the
issue of what's going on in the
um
social justice oriented academic
disciplines and then there's a deeper
issue of
how
people view the world individually and
collectively yes through the lens of a
belief system and the probability that
that
belief system will take on something
approximating the trappings of a
religious movement
yes
so so so
that's a deeper question i mean one of
the things that i discussed continually
with sam harris when we had our series
of debates was
the
question of the inescapability of
something approximating a religious
framework to orient people in
relationship to action in the world
because i like i happen to believe that
a framework like that is inescapable the
question is not whether you're going to
have one it's which one you're going to
have and what is it going to be rooted
in
and i mean
one of the things i think that both
nietzsche and dostoevsky warned people
about in the late 19th century was that
um what what this isn't a quote from
either of them but it's something
approximating someone else whose name i
don't remember um
he who believes in nothing will end up
believing in anything
and that and there's something
there's something in that that's
extraordinarily deep as far as i'm
concerned all right so you were
interested in religious phenomenology
and then you guys started to see that
um
as far as you were concerned a variety
of different quasi-academic or academic
movements were taking on the trappings
of a of a of religious
they were starting to look religious in
their approach and in their application
of their beliefs right determined that
you would focus on the on the social
justice end of it right the community
for example was definitely engaging in
of course they had kind of their uh
their unique
vocabulary that they speak to one
another and identify one another by uh
which is kind of like an ecclesiastical
vocabulary but of social justice and
then they
were
um definitely involved what what they
call political correctness is in
practice virtually identical to what you
see with people crying blasphemy
um
so these parallels started to stick out
at the same time the way that we started
looking at the real peer review twitter
account and the way that they seem to be
producing their knowledge that they
could then refer to virtually
replicates special revelation the they
came up with their ideas they believe
that they came from some morally backed
source
of uh of goodness and then put them
forth and then were they were morally
vetted
and given an epistemological status they
didn't deserve as a result
why do you think the source is
the source at the time i had no idea but
now after having done the project i
think the source is actually what i've
come to call a post-modern mythology
that
our social reality is conditioned upon
use of language and representation and
it's all done in service to power
dynamics that underlie how society works
those power dynamics are trapped up in
identity
and
um mediated primarily through language
and in media okay
okay so i've identified the sources of
that not and not only me obviously but
i've identified the sources of that
belief with the french postmodernist
movement fundamentally other people
trace some of it back farther to
what's essentially something
approximating a marxist doctrine which
is the doctrine of which is a doctrine
of power relations i would say sure you
have any criticisms or further comments
on that
let's call it genealogy genealogy or lin
or
helen
yeah
helen good
yeah no i i largely agree i i with the
idea that we had a quite a profound
epistemic shift in the late 60s with the
rise of the post-modernists i disagree
with people who
kind of relate this closely to marxism i
i think it's clear that they they have a
common ancestor and that they have
certain ideas
in common but
if we conflate marxism and
post-modernism
um too closely on more than those yeah
that that sort of oppressor and
oppressed group that sort of um
um false consciousness these sort of key
ideas which really were floating around
at the same time and they've come up in
the same place if we conflate those too
closely and we are not looking at the
really profound differences in
epistemology in which
marxism was really trying to continue a
modernist project it was totalitarian it
was objectivist mostly and it went sort
of in a straight line and the
if there was a word for the extremes of
marxism it is totalitarianism if there's
a word for the extremes of
post-modernism it's disintegration it's
fragmentation so we're looking now at
something very different something very
intangible
that is coming in and it's saying we we
cannot access
an objective truth everything is created
in discourses in powers of in systems of
power and privilege okay so why in the
world is power privileged then
i mean it still seems that the
post-modernists are willing to
uh assume that the pursuit of power is
first of all obvious that everyone's
pursuing it but that it's also okay for
those who don't have it to pursue it so
it's not as if they've abandoned the
idea as far as i can tell of a of a
linear narrative towards some end the
end seems to me to be power
and so why is that justifiable from the
postmodern perspective given that
linear movement and meta-narratives
aren't justifiable
because of this change that happened in
the late 80s so when sokol for example
he he did his hoax what he was looking
at was this quite sort of pure
post-modernism this um very sort of
intangible idea that an objective
reality can't exist that we can't grasp
anything that everything is a construct
but what happened in the 80s gradually
was that this just after prolific
amounts of writing it just kind of
fizzled because once you've
disintegrated and dismantled absolutely
everything and it's all in a mess on the
floor you have got nowhere to go with
this so we started seeing then the rise
in materialist feminism first of all um
and then within sort of critical race
approaches intersectionality in queer
theory
in post-colonialism particularly we
started seeing a change towards okay so
everything is a cultural construct
but we can't address anything if we
don't accept that a certain group of
people in a certain place at a certain
time experience certain things so what
we're looking at now is an objective
reality that oppression and systems of
power exist
but
but everything else
everything else is socially constructed
so the fundamental transcendent
but that construct has power yes it is
objectively true that power is
benefiting straight white men and
disadvantaging women of color trans
women etc so this this was the the
change that happened then
so now it's politically actionable and
this i mean kimberly crenshaw put this
most explicitly when she said it's
politics applied to post-modern theory
okay so that shift now okay so we want
to get this straight because
it's very very important so
you just you distinguished the
postmodern movement from the marxist
movement because the marxism marxists
were still moving in a
single direction and you considered that
still part of the modernist project you
equated marxism and post-modernism
in so far as they both adopt let's say
an oppressor oppressive oppression
narrative
yes although many other things do too
and often that that's quite warranted i
mean the the american
revolution for example was an oppressor
repressed
revolution there's no doubt that there's
no doubt that power and power
differentials exist the issue is not
there are other realities that might be
considered
exactly the issue is whether that we're
seeing them truly
yes well and and whether it's reasonable
to reduce everything to a single
dimension of motivation so the modern
project collapses into its own nihilism
and something emerges out of the ashes
and that's the uh assumption that a
transcendent reality does in fact exist
but that the only defining feature of
that transcendent reality is the
existence of power in the existence of
power differential
but then yes
and that's associated with identity okay
but then the question becomes is there's
a question that goes underneath that
even which is well why is it that why is
it that that is accepted as the
fundamental reality because there's no
rationale for that in post-modernism
itself in fact the auditors should
criticize that presumption they do
they do very much and this is the
argument that goes on repeatedly with
the old-style post-modernists saying
this isn't post-modernism
and so we we've tended to call it
applied post-modernism um john nurse
called it um the pomod cluster because
it's just a set of ideas about identity
about power about privilege about
language the importance of
of language and um
and and hierarchies and things which
have come from post-modernism which have
got politicized and then within activism
have got condensed into kind of
user-friendly chunks and further
bastardized so we can't
we can't take this away from
post-modernism it didn't come from
anywhere else but neither is it the
the pure sort of deconstructive um or
post-structuralist or any of that of
that whole sort of massive range of um
theory that it that existed from the
late 60s into the mid 80s that's
that died it's it's gone it's fragmented
itself as it was always bound to do
so to to drive to your question about
why or how they justify this change um
i'll just say we we called this
this set of disciplines or approaches
grievance studies for a reason it's
about grievances it's the politics of
grievance so they feel aggrieved
therefore they feel justified in trying
to disrupt power they see that exists
and to claim power for themselves it's
social revenge that's what they're
that's what their animus is that's their
moral justification
for
for continuing to fragment and and to
chase the very thing they say
is
you know the great corrupter of man
which is power okay so it doesn't so it
doesn't really matter if this is true
and i do
i have some sympathy with that claim
it doesn't matter that there are
philosophical incoherences within the
structure within the intellectual
structure at all
what matters is that
there's an animus and a motive and the
motive is fundamentally something
approximating revenge why why would you
say look why would you say revenge
and not justice like and this this goes
to another issue which is obviously all
three of you oppose this movement
and we've already decided in this
discussion that it's something like the
revenge of the marginalized but the
marginalized could well object well this
isn't revenge you only see it that way
because you're part of the privileged
power group and it's actually a search
for
uh it's a search for it's a search a
genuine search for justice
and also most of the marginalized aren't
social justice orientated that that's
what we have to remember this is
speaking on behalf of women and racial
and sexual minorities most members of
every group are do not ascribe to it
they're they're politically diverse so
it's um okay so that was presumptuous
that's good so that's one of the reasons
that
that the claim for the pursuit of
justice is invalidated it's that there's
no evidence whatsoever that the activist
types who dominate these disciplines are
valid representatives of the communities
that they purport to stand for and in
fact if you survey the communities
themselves
uh in any reasonable manner then the
communities indicate their lack of
agreement with with this way of looking
at the world yeah yes okay okay and
of course there is also the the
complicating element that nearly always
appears that you do have kernels of
truth on both sides of that discussion
there are legitimate questions of
justice that are being tied up into this
and then there are
legitimate reasons to see it as being
motivated primarily by something
approximating revenge or grievance or
reparations or something like that and
they get intertwined and as you were
mentioning with anytime you're working
with post-modern epistemologies there's
no reason to expect consistency they
reject consistency as as as a bug in the
system uh they're unrepentant
unrepentant about being inconsistent
that's no small point and and i think
for people watching that that point
needs to be punched home so jim could
you speak to a little more about that
well yeah it's um
the the idea that you would be
consistent is
one of the ideas that would be caught up
in the western philosophical tradition
as they would phrase it it's caught up
in the exact tradition that was bred of
white and male
power
and so that needs to be disrupted
because that power inherently from the
perspective of this uh world view that
power inherently corrupts but more
importantly and it inherently always
acts to preserve and maintain and
legitimize itself okay so the demand for
consistency becomes itself an act of
oppression against people exactly yep
that that all seems reasonable to me so
so look so so here's a peculiar thing
and it's an observation of something
approximating let's say that freudian
notion of projection
um
the people who are pushing this
viewpoint aren't legitimate
representatives of their communities in
any real sense of the matter and
they push a particular viewpoint that
has very little academic credibility as
far as i'm concerned and is primarily
concerned with political activism and
with the
obtaining or the justification of
obtaining power
now
we could assume that this is being done
on behalf of the people who are putting
forward the doctrine
and so to me see i've come to understand
that part of the reason that people
cling to their belief systems is because
they have
their the reason they have the moral
authority to occupy the hierarchical
position that society has granted them
is because they're regarded as experts
in a in a belief structure
and if they're that their claim to that
expertise is questioned then their moral
justification for occupying their
position is
eradicated and it's their position that
gives them purpose in life and that
protects them from uncertainty and
anxiety it's not the belief structure
itself you see it's true
they're experts in the belief system and
that justifies their position in the
hierarchy so they put forward this claim
to continue
justifying the fact that they occupy
very perversely and this is the freudian
projection issue very perversely the
very positions of power whose existence
they criticize this would be the
university professor types in particular
that seems
reasonable to you or or is there
something wrong with that line no that
comports actually with what i've drawn
from reading john height for example who
talks about psycho
psycho social evaluation
the way that human beings do that with
one another how we identify where we
stand in our social and moral
hierarchies uh and how we where we
position ourselves and others and each
other in relation to one another and
that one of those three dimensions he
named divinity and so that would be
the the part you're speaking to so we
gain we gain status in the hierarchy
through our closeness of kin so if you
and i are friends you rank me higher
than i probably deserve because that's
how humans do and we gain satisfy
reputation and that's why we care what
michael jordan thinks about politics and
we gain status by um our moral standing
which is what john height called
divinity and of course he explored it
primarily in the happiness hypothesis
with regard to his trips i think to
india and seeing a traditional religion
and then comparing that directly against
the so-called weird societies in western
democracies and
i think that what we're actually seeing
in a lot of these cases is we're seeing
partly at least
people are acting out
um
what what often gets conflated with
religion in fact is that they're acting
out the need to
fulfill or or participate in that third
dimension of psychosocial evaluation
although in secular societies we throw
out the the explicit religious structure
for it and we
have to find it in other ways so that's
what you're actually talking about they
they occupy a moral expertise that moral
expertise gives them standing within the
prevailing um
moral and social milieu and then that
defines their place in the community as
in both in terms of prestige and in
terms of hierarchical so they're
basically acting out precisely what
they're accusing all other disciplines
of doing
and the different irony okay and the
difference is the see the thing is the
difference as far as i'm concerned is
that
if you look at a discipline like
engineering which i think is perhaps as
close to the polar opposite of this as
might be managed
one of the things that engineers do is
look at the world in a
certain way but another thing they do is
build bridges
exactly right that's right
there's an objective real world uh
direction to their
to their philosophizing and their belief
that results in something of tangible
and universally recognized benefit to
the community at large
and something that can fail
right right also that's very important
okay now okay next issue so
now
the first issue the first of the next
two issues saying is
why is it that you three
found yourself in the position where you
decided to take this on as a critical
project and why is it that so few other
academics are doing so
i don't have good answers for why so few
academics are doing so because i don't
want to just blatantly call people
cowards that i don't know
but you don't get treated well for
fighting but let's dig into that a bit
okay because i think i think cowardice
is one or fear and let's let's not fear
experience let's call it fear and let's
also note that the fear is well
justified very justice yeah
that's correct right well peter you're
in a great position to speak to that
because look what's happening to you
yeah so i don't know if you want to go
down the path of what's happening to me
yet but i i think you're right our
mutual friend brett weinstein said to me
that academia where we had a
conversation about academia
self-selecting for cowardice and i think
it's a process that people go through
before they have tenure where they're
afraid to buck the system afraid to
challenge ideas they're afraid to
question because they won't get tenure
and then once they do get tenure then
they won't you know they won't climb
that that so
the same thing happens in corporations
at the middle manager level like it's
not a disease that's endemic to
to academia no no it's not but it's one
variable in a suite of variables that we
have to take a look at the other one is
the culture in which the cultural milieu
that jim spoke about in which people are
terrified to be called sexist racist
bigots they don't challenge those
i'm even hesitant to say the things they
don't challenge but i'll say it like
race and iq or and
trans issues trans bathroom issues if
you teach an ethics class people won't
really dig into those
issues in a substantive way but i think
that there are many factors
but not just one but it's interesting
that people will come up to jim and
myself and i haven't spoken explicitly
to helen about this and they'll thank me
yep oh thank you so much oh great can
you do that publicly no no i no no no no
yeah the same thing happened to me so so
i think peter we should talk about
what's happening to you because look we
can talk about fear
we could talk about cowardice we could
talk about justifiable fear because
there's no there's no pleasure in being
isolated and mobbed and undermined and
fired right so
the the apprehension of that is not
merely cowardice it's it's realistic and
i'm not underestimating the potential
the additional role of cowardice but
then there's another issue too here that
i've been thinking about it's like
to me many of these post-modern activist
propositions are so fundamentally absurd
and so academically weak that most
serious social scientists and pretty
much all serious stem
types the stem researchers have just
ignored them yeah you know
they thought they were beneath contempt
well i just seriously mean that because
when i look at an idea you know a
brilliant postmodern activist idea like
intersectionality or like patriarchy
theory or like white privilege all you
have to do is spend an hour thinking
through those things critically and you
realize that there's absolutely nothing
whatsoever to them methodologically or
conceptually yeah
as as jim was saying you know that there
can be a kernel
of truth in things but when they are
theoretically built
up i mean obviously they're they're
there there are societies in which white
people are regarded more positively on
average but this is something that can
be measured empirically which can be
looked at which can be talked about and
we don't actually have that we we have
imaginary knapsacks and talk of
complicity and um and epistemological um
environments in which white people
literally can't understand what's going
on so we get it we get a big mess and
it's it's the kernel of truth is in
there and so that gives them the
opportunity to kind of retreat to this
sensible space where they'll say but
there is racism and that there is sexism
well yes of course there is but what
you're doing here with these theoretical
concepts is
is not looking realistically and
reasonably at that right they also
there's also a problem of univariate
reduction right it's like okay well
racism is a problem and sexism is a
problem we'll say and well any form of
discrimination that isn't associated
with the hypothetical outcome of the
project is a problem but there are
methods that everyone who's a decent
social scientist knows to measure those
and to estimate the proportion of the
variance in the outcome problem that
those issues are accounting for and the
post-modern activist types do absolutely
none of that yeah
yeah what you just said i mean why would
they
because they don't care about they're
agenda-driven and they're they're not
truth-oriented so
there's there'd be no point to even
think like that well they also can't
they don't have the methods
exactly so so that also provides
additional impetus for being motivated
to criticize those that do because it's
a lot easier than facing the reality and
the consequences of your own ignorance
let's talk about what's happening to you
because i want to know about the cost
that you're burying for this and then
we'll go back to why you guys decided to
do what you did
so psu like many college campuses has
become an ideological community and i've
demonstrated that i don't fit that mold
and i suspect that they're going to go
to great lengths to get rid of me so
what's happened is i've been found
guilty of not seeking irb approval and
okay you should tell the viewers what
that means and provide some background
detail because it's okay
okay so irb approval is there's
uh
it's called irb institutional review
board and whenever you do a an
experiment on human subjects human
beings or animals by the way
you need to go through the irb and you
need to get permission and you detail
exactly what it is that you're going to
do and they say to you well you have to
change this you have to do this don't do
this et cetera and then they give you
permission
okay now these these systems just a
little more background these systems
were originally set up fundamentally to
monitor relatively or potentially
dangerous medical experimentation of
human beings but they've expanded their
purview so that now it's impossible for
anybody who's an academic in any
institution to even interview people
without
seeking permission from a very vast
and rigid bureaucratic structure that's
easily politicized
yeah they came out of and they do exist
for good reasons the nuremberg trials
manually etc etc and people were and
that envelope has has uh the number of
experiments or the number of things that
are caught under that umbrella continues
to increase we can talk about the ethics
of the rb more generally but in our case
or particularly my case
the irb has no jim and and uh james and
helen don't fall under the auspices of
psu's rb so they can't be sanctioned i
however allegedly can can be sanctioned
so i've been found guilty on that first
charge
which how and why now look let's let's
tell everybody you guys published a
sequence of papers how many papers in in
journals is how many so we
wrote twenty seven of them were accepted
and four were
three are on the published of
publication for example okay
okay so
let's get it straight here these are
satirical publications that were
published in hypothetically serious
academic journals and now peter you're
being gone after for not seeking
institutional review board permission to
publish studies that didn't exist
yeah two things that's the first thing
i've been found guilty of that and it's
escalated to the
provost and the president of the
university and i believe that the
provost is a former gender studies
scholar and i'll just names of those
people just
i'll let that sit there i do
i do i can't pronounce the president's
name to be blunt with you
uh and the provost is a new provost i'm
not avoiding the question i just don't
know well that's fine we can always put
that in the description of the video so
so what are you guilty of exactly
because these studies didn't exist you
didn't undertake research on any human
subjects
they've decided that the journals
editors and peer reviewers are the human
subjects that we were studying so not
the studies themselves but go up one
level of meta to the fact that we were
studying the culture of um journal
journal review and publication so the
editors who are not anonymous and then
the anonymous peer reviewers are
considered to be the human subjects of
ours and that's supposed to be i suppose
i see so that's supposed to be
distinguishable from you thinking and
writing about the things that you
encounter in your own life for example
which is also what now supposed to be
subject to irb approval
yeah so so
okay so there's a lot of moving parts to
this so we need to break it down i
wonder i want to continue with the
excuse me
guilty of not seeking irb approval that
can include turn up determination from
my current position
and
uh i just want to speak to that before i
talk about the data fabrication charges
so i i don't agree with the decision but
i definitely understand the pressures
that they have on them to do something
who knows what's happening
pressures from who these activist types
are a very tiny proportion of the
population so and when we're talking
about pressure what exactly do we mean
well there was an anonymous hit piece by
12 or 11 of my colleagues published in
the student newspaper the portland
vanguard
and they may be a small representation
it's unclear to me in in academia i
don't think they're a small proportion
they are a large and i think that they
wield institutionalized power and have
weaponized things like title ix against
people they don't like
um so there's that
but i do want to say i i don't really
know what's happening behind the scenes
i my guess is these
this group is extraordinarily vocal but
what they're faced with now is a
decision for what kind of university
they want to be is it one that uses
power to support freedom of inquiry and
pursue the truth or do they want to
protect social justice at all costs
and the fabrication of data thing is
interesting because that's an ongoing
it's a currently ongoing investigation
and again those are very very serious
charges
let's look at it here too like there's a
very big difference and let's get this
very clear between a self-admitted
satire
which which had historical precedent and
which has ethical justification even if
you don't agree with the justification
and data fabrication data fabrication
occurs when you put data forward and you
claim that it's a truthful
representation of
a real world situation
and obviously that's distinct from
satire and comedy everyone understands
that distinction well the i the idea
is that
those rules were put in there for very
good reasons and that is people wouldn't
use that to advance their careers which
uh and they wanted to hide the results
so they don't didn't want anybody to see
what it was
so
the problem with that is that it would
as sokol wrote that it would contaminate
the
research lines in perpetuity
so
what the success of our project depended
upon it being revealed so that no longer
applies
and the idea that we would somehow not
only have i not benefited from this but
this has come at a tremendous cost to me
so
it's
it's in my opinion it is uh a grotesque
abuse of
what it means to fabricate data
and
uh i mean it'd be interesting to see
it'll be interesting to see what happens
and be interesting to see when it goes
to court okay and so so well yeah tell
me about the proceedings
when it goes to court what kind of court
is it going to
i don't know i mean first let me even
take a step back from there
so if you look at the timeline of events
when this occurred and i have that off
top my head but
uh
the
the that when i was found guilty from
the irb there's been a series of uh
not seeking irb approval there was a
series of a time when the university
president could just end this
just like that you can say well we're
going to put a a letter of reprimand in
your uh we're going to
we'll start you've already been they
could end this they could end
so the irb is policing its own
its own policies here
yeah so that was for the irb charge the
open the the data falsification charge
is open and still being investigated uh
and that actually started i think like
two or three days after we went public
he got an email and said you've been
summoned to a meeting okay we were all
in portland together at the time in
october the irb which purports to be an
ethics committee doesn't have any
problem with the ethics of policing
themselves
i know
okay so we might want to point that out
very strongly they're not in a position
to be policing accordance with their own
policies no there's a conflict of
interest clearly
there's something appalling about that
and it's not surprising because there's
plenty of calling about the
institutional review boards um
it's been escalated to the president and
again the president could just decide
just like that you know we're just going
to put a letter in this file of
reprimand and we're going to move on and
i think that the whole problem would be
uh
ended except my my guess is that there
are a lot of people crying for vengeance
right now against me right so they want
to hang you out to dry as an object
lesson to people who would dare to do
the things that you three have done
because i'm a heretic and i'm a
blasphemer and i have attacked their
cannons
uh and there has to be some price that's
paid for this that's my guess on their
thinking and then the fabrication of
data charge again that's a very serious
charge
and those rules are put in put in place
for a reason
i don't think a court would find
i mean it would be interesting to see
when this goes to quarter if it does
even go to court
the idea that this was fabricated either
for personal gain or that would have to
not be revealed at some time and that
the future lines of literature would be
contaminated and polluted it's just it's
just not true
and i think
also a clear it's a career-ending charge
so that's partly why it's been brought
against you right data fabrication there
isn't anything
well there isn't anything worse within
the domain of science than you can do
that you can do than that
it's really unfortunate and preposterous
because the data fabrication occurred
intentionally in the sense that we
wanted to find out if they could detect
because we we suspected from the very
beginning as we were kind of discussing
earlier that these people who largely
work in the humanities are not equipped
to do social science but that's
ultimately what they're basically doing
and so we wanted to see if they could
detect
utterly ridiculous data or data that
were clearly cherry picked or data or
conclusions i should say that we're
drawn from data that aren't warranted
and so we wrote papers that included
in this case for example a dog park
paper just
transparently ridiculous data in fact
the first draft of that paper even we we
knew the data were so bad that they were
probably going to ask to see it and we
thought that's the end of the road okay
so let's go through the papers then so
so we'll talk about the dog park paper
why don't you go through the papers that
have been published just briefly
okay what they are and and and tell us
why they're transparently ridiculous
because that's also absolutely attention
right because
yeah yeah the dog park paper um was
the first one we had accepted in
february and it
chronicles uh a it's a feminist scholar
putatively that's chronicling dog rape
culture by examining dog humping in
portland dog parks and
then draws conclusions from that using
black feminist criminology as a tool to
conclude that it would be appropriate to
train men as we trained dogs if only it
were politically feasible so we have to
come up with metaphorical equivalents
and that it concludes that oppression of
dogs based on perceived gender is real
and the reason that that was
allegedly concluded was we claimed that
um humans intervened and broke up
uh gay dog rape much more frequently and
vigorously than they broke up
straight dog rape
and the pain i mean it's already a bit
weird
about these things the paper the paper
included for instance the detail that
the the scholar sat in the dog park for
a thousand hours over the course of a
year but never in the heavy rain
and
observed uh and then examined personally
closely examined the genitals of
just short of ten thousand dogs which if
you've been to a dog park you probably
realize the same people bring their dogs
almost every day because it's there's
not 10 000 dogs in any dog park in a
year but never mind that somewhat likely
to develop a reputation
for looking at dogs genitals yeah i
think so and then immediately turning to
ask their owners excuse me sir could you
tell me your sexual orientation
that's what the paper says we
handles of ten thousand dogs
generals of ten thousand dogs and then
interrogated their owners as to their
sexual orientations okay it includes
details that are irrelevant like whether
dogs use the bathroom in the in the on
other dogs or in the the food bowl um
the water bowl
it talked about you know the way people
would break up dog fights like doing
jumping jacks and singing we thought
this data was so absurd that we put in
the first draft which the journal saw
a line that said that we took the data
and put it in a recycle bin so that they
couldn't possibly ask us to produce it
because we thought oh man if they ask
for this data which is so stupid it's
over so we said that we recycled the
data which is already its own research
missed practice and no problem you know
the journal was like oh just write it up
okay i can't believe we're having this
conversation
listen the more we talk about this the
more ridiculous it gets okay okay so
let's go on to another paper let's see
jesus that's just un unbearable
there was the paper where we argued that
if straight white or straight man i'm
sorry it doesn't matter what their race
is if straight men were to anally
penetrate themselves with sex toys
they'd become less transphobic and more
feminist
um
which apparently got picked up have that
conversation either you may not want to
have that conversation but this data was
this this conclusion which was called a
truly marvelous paper and an important
contribution to knowledge by one of its
reviewers uh this paper was published um
this paper was based on interviews with
13 men
only eight of whom were straight
of course it was all interview data and
it was just
just people saying the most ridiculous
things about their experience of
sticking things in their own butts and
then their feelings about feminism and
uh
concern for rape culture and and their
attitudes about trans people and so on
including one so-called social
conservative who was quoted saying he
didn't want to take part in some stupid
liberal study about sticking things up
his butt i
mean almost impossible to have looked at
this and not thought you know
something's going on here but instead
they thought truly marvelous paper
important contribution to knowledge it's
that that's a second paper a third paper
um was an ethnography allegedly of a 70
some odd year old man who went to
hooters with his brazilian jiu jitsu
class
after workouts and sat there and
basically just womanized for
hours upon hours it recorded
something like 10 000 hours or sorry 10
000 minutes of of
conversation at the table which could
all be summarized and this was an
example of clear cherry picking of data
the only features of the conversation
that were relevant were the way that the
guys hit on the surfers or talked about
the servers you know various body parts
or most importantly how much they
enjoyed the fact that hooters provides
them a place that they can go
and tell young attractive women what to
do in a situation in which they are
contractually obligated to fulfill those
those orders like literally double
entendre on the word order like please i
would like some beer that's an order so
um that was an example of clear cherry
picking and of course deriving
ridiculous conclusions uh didn't you
guys know while you were doing this that
you were going to get yourself in like a
boatload of trouble i mean and now i see
when you're talking about it you laugh
and so you still got a sense of humor
which is quite a remarkable thing but i
mean you you did this for a long time
and like
yeah it's hard to believe actually that
you did manage to do it i had some some
moments especially where
i mean we were always aware that there
would be a backlash and then when i
started actually signing the transfer of
copyright
documents to have the papers actually
published i started to feel a little
like you know we might really get in
some trouble for this but at this point
we're kind of in deep and uh might as
well carry on and try to finish the
experiment we had intended to try to
write papers for 12 months
and then spend six to eight months kind
of you know following up the academic
publishing process is slow
they do the review you get it back a
couple months later you have to do edits
it takes maybe another month or two
before they accept or whatever then
publication maybe another couple months
later so all that slow so we wanted to a
lot you know six eight months after 12
months of writing and that was the
intended duration that we should be
wrapping up the project now if we didn't
get busted but about late summer the the
dog park paper got picked up
um
by some journalists in the real peer
review and got made fun of and we
realized we were probably not going to
make it to the end of our intended year
and a half ish
time span so we ended up writing for 10
total months which is a bit of time and
then we had a lot of papers still under
review which was really a shame because
i'm fairly certain that they had to go
in but i do want to speak to that jordan
because somebody had to do this yeah
okay why
why
because the ideology because the perfect
these professors are looking at their
classrooms as an ideology
and they're attempting to indoctrinate
people into
things about reality that have nothing
to do with reality they've placed an
agenda ahead of the truth
and it's corroding our institutions and
it's eroding trust in those
universities and institutions
and
you identified the problem many people
identified the problem but something had
to be done about it beyond
identification and calling these people
out we needed to show that we needed to
de-legitimize these cannons because
their
the way that they were coming to
knowledge is just epistemologically to
say it's not rigorous as child is is
charitable
so they're kind of a few pieces to that
right so you everybody as we mentioned a
little bit earlier we touched upon um is
now familiar with the idea that racism
and sexism don't seem to mean the same
thing they meant 10 years ago
you used to be able to say racist and
sexist and immense discrimination based
on race or sex and it could go in any
direction but now it's got this this
power dynamic privilege plus power stuff
everybody's talking about privilege so
that's everywhere but if you that's one
dimension that it's impossible to avoid
that these sociological or grievance
studies definitions for concepts are are
everywhere but there are also two other
pieces of evidence one that we saw
before we started
um that would be a paper that was done
by charlata stern who documented
how
insular gender studies is how they
literally took
um the years since stephen pinker
published the blank slate 2003
until 2015 or 16 she looked at a bunch
of papers got a sample of those papers
and determined whether or not they
incorporated or ignored the uh
information that pinker had shared as a
as a as a test and found that there was
an overwhelming amount of just putting
the blinkers on and pretending that
biology still doesn't exist and and that
human nature is totally social part of
that's not a pretense either is that the
people oh sure who are well the pretense
here i mean the reason it's not a
pretense is because as far as i can tell
the people who are in these disciplines
know absolutely nothing whatsoever about
biology no they don't want to that's
not true the less you know about biology
the more you don't want to know that you
need to know something about it because
it's a daunting task yeah i want to
speak to that for a moment if i may so
at my university there's a course
offered on the philosophy of race and
it would seem to me that a minimum
qualification one would need to teach
that is
that one would have to have some kind of
degree in evolutionary biology
but
that does not seem to be the case and
i think again we're seeing consistently
you know race is such an explosive
explosive topic but
when you start with the idea that you
have the truth and then you work
backward and cherry-pick the literature
and in this case it's extraordinarily
easy because you just go to these
the journals and the canons of
literature and then you start teaching
that so what happens then is the kind of
the self-fulfillment of the postmodern
condition is that they then manufacture
pieces of information that people take
as knowledge that's right
we see that happening in our
institutions now and it's nobody's
calling them out on it so again i say
that because it speaks to your point of
why did we do this because the public
trust in these institutions is being
eroded and we're teaching our kids
things that are just not true they're
just
they're totally untethered to reality
even though some of these people may be
very well meaning and there's always a
citation we learned there's always a
psychiatrist always a citation you want
to find something that says anything
ridiculous about sex toys and anal
taken care of there's
questions power dynamics using that
already there's always
that that really is that is the
important thing to sort of realize about
what we did i mean all of that
ridiculous stuff that that jim was
saying earlier he we were able to say
that because there was already something
out there which led to it or said it
itself and so if you're actually looking
at what our project is something that's
very important to look at is our
references
because to make
it's it's satire i mean some of it like
the dog park really yeah it's there's
there's humorous there's a very humorous
element in it but
on a on a sort of deeper level what it
is is just gathering so much of this
nonsense together
citing it putting it in there and then
kind of making it do whatever it
whatever we wanted it to do that that
was
was the project um
so your point is that you had to embed
your satire within a pre-existent
literature or
it it couldn't have flowed and that's
right that was actually like you could
papers
like they really i mean a lot of the the
some of the academics have said well we
haven't been fooled because we still
stand by the papers what you wrote was
reasonable because they are
indistinguishable and that really was
kind of the point we wanted to have
we've ended up with a really good
resource for anyone who wants to know
what is out there they can look at our
our references they can look at the
arguments that they enabled us to make
they can look at how the reviewers
what they rejected us for what they
accepted us for what they pushed us to
do
there's a very clear pattern but because
it is so complicated and so few people
have taken the time it would take to
read all of our papers to read all of
the comments to follow up our um our
references
it's not always clear that what we're
doing is putting it right in the cannon
that is why you know you know the other
issue and this this has to do with the
motivation of other academics not to be
bothered with this let's say is that
the stat that i'm most familiar with is
that about 80 percent of humanity's
papers get cited zero times and the
problem is that even to go after very
bad ideas in an academically rigorous
way is actually an extraordinarily
daunting task and it might be daunting
in direct proportion to the to the uh
appallingness of the ideas so for
example if you're grading a very bad
undergraduate essay
it's way more difficult to grade a d
paper than it is to grade a b
because a d paper has so many errors in
it you don't even know where to start
right the words are wrong the sentences
are wrong the sentences aren't organized
in the paragraphs the paragraphs are
chaotic and disjointed and the whole
thing makes no sense and you actually
have to
there isn't a level of criticism that
can't be applied to a very bad paper and
so it's absolutely exhausting
intellectually apart from the danger
that it poses
personally and so
you know before we assume that it's mere
lack of character on the part of our
fellow academics that is stopping them
from taking a stand against such things
although i do buy the sort of entrenched
cowardice idea that emerges as
perhaps an inevitable consequence of
participating in a structured hierarchy
um
it's there are many more reasons why
this is flourished including the
inappropriate what would you call it
subsidization of these viewpoints for
the last 50 years
yeah yeah i think that's right it's
really really
painstaking to pour through these papers
and as a as a person you know with a
commitment to science and a background
in science it wasn't just even
painstaking i actually went into
some pretty
dark places like dark psychological
places i remember reading the
so i mentioned reading the glaciology
paper earlier the feminist glaciology
but i didn't read it in depth when we
first found it but when we started to do
this project i wanted to emulate it and
write one about feminist astronomy
yeah right right and i read the thing in
tremendous depth and with great care
taking notes all the way through and and
you know preparing so i could could
write a facsimile and i shut down i mean
i just almost locked myself in a room by
myself for three days in a dark
depression
i had to talk him i had to talk him down
because he just got so despairing and he
was just
quoting bits to me and he was going to
look at this how can this be
look the same thing happened to me when
i was writing 12 rules for life i wrote
a chapter called don't bother children
when they're skateboarding and it's
about the discouragement let's say of of
primarily of young men as a direct
consequence of this the kind of rhetoric
that we're discussing and like that made
me unbearable to my family for about
three months because the more i studied
it the more well it has a really
fragmenting and chaotic effect on on you
psychologically and i've also seen this
manifested in my students
you know who undergo this kind of
activist uh uh indoctrination
it's such a it's such a corrosive and
cynical view of the world that all were
we're all in it in our groups and that
all the groups are fighting one another
for power and that that's the
fundamental transcendent reality it's
just yeah now imagine imagine the sort
of person who looks at that as an
epistemological and moral virtue and who
teaches that to their students who
attempts to
indoctrinate their students into these
not even they don't even rise to the
level of being false in terms of these
morally dangerous ideas and then they
think that they're better people as a
result and then they think that if
somebody calls them out on it they're
evil well okay so let's look and look at
this too so when height and lukinov
wrote the coddling of the american mind
one point they pointed out as the
american psychological association and
the american psychiatric association
should have
that all of the safe space and and
doctrines and trigger warning doctrines
and and and that sort of thing
um and the speech codes for example that
are increasingly forbidding even sarcasm
are
exactly the opposite of the approach
that you would take if you were a
trained psychologist trying to produce
people who are more resilient you
actually make them weaker and more
anxiety provoked and more anxiety prone
more depressed and more hopeless and i
think the evidence for that's absolutely
clear and i think it's appalling that it
wasn't clinical psychologists or
psychiatrists who pointed it out
and so it is that the these doctrines
are being put forth for the benefit of
those who formulate the doctrines and
that the students are sacrificial
victims in that
in that process yeah and there's more
there's one more piece that i think is
important it goes back to it excuse me
what jim said about
not not seeing that a contradiction is
problematic because the whole idea of
contradiction is white science or
western science and that's that's
problematic
is that we found that these folks don't
really value discourse and dialogue
and so
they don't really value having ideas
challenged and questioned that's not
their their reason for teaching these
ideas in the first place and if i may
give you a quick example
excuse me
portland state university wants to
include or has included at this point a
a course on native american philosophy
which which i think is a great idea
and
well somebody in the audience asked a
question and and the question was i went
to a presentation and the question this
individual asked was well what do we do
as settlers as colonialists when we want
to question or challenge these
ideas and native american philosophy
and the presenter said
you know i've struggled with this it's
very difficult for me but the bottom
line was it shouldn't it should be
exempt from traditional
tools that we have used for other
disciplines you know the dialectic the
challenging and so that first of all
that places me in an almost impossible
position
what am i supposed to do say you know
why is it exempt it should play by the
rules of every other philosophy because
then i become the guy who hates
wester who hates um
uh indigenous people who hates
indigenous philosophy and then i'm the
tool of the patriarchy which gets back
to what your question were asked before
is why do we have this
violence in academia and what's the
problem with it so i i think part of the
problem is that these folks don't value
discourse they don't value dialogue they
don't value open expression they don't
val they view that and again there's a
paper for this they view that as a type
of violence words are a type of minds a
type of verbal violence and so then
their students develop brutal
epistemologies because they've never
heard the other side of the story right
and they developed them just when they
should be developing resilient
resiliency exactly correct
yeah and as a litmus test i always i
always ask folks why who are gender
studies in my class or study in in the
grievance studies fields
why is it martha nussbaum's criticism of
judith butler taught
here a single single student who says
yes i've learned about that in my
classes well they don't they don't teach
that because they have a prevailing
moral orthodoxy and they want to
indoctrinate students with it and
they've kind of hijacked the
administration and as i said before
they've weaponized offices of diversity
inclusion etc to punish people who are
heretics and who question or challenge
this okay so we're going to run out of
time here we're running down to about 10
minutes here so i want to
here's a question that i want to
raise to all three of you have two i
think one is
why in the world should anybody outside
of academia care about this that's the
first thing and a great question very
careful answer that and the second is um
for each of you what's been the personal
consequence of this and would you have
repeated it if you knew what the
consequences were going to be so let's
start with the first one why in the
world should any why in the world should
anyone care that some half-witted
academic journal published an insane
paper by three renegade uh academics
about
what about dog rape of all the absurd
of of all the observed observed topics
it's so surreal that it seems
virtually incomprehensible sensible
people should avoid it so what's the
answer to that
well go ahead allen
yes
if we we are
the university is
it it is our source of knowledge
production if we look back through
history when our cultures were christian
the new knowledge about this was coming
from the universities when we had the
scientific
revolution when we went into the
enlightenment this was coming from the
universities these things don't stay in
the universities we have seen it is
coming out in
it's what has essentially happened with
the kind of identity studies that we're
looking at is that it has been made
directly actionable by activists it has
been tagged on to the end of the civil
rights movements and liberal feminism
and gay pride when those movements have
started to see diminishing returns and
people wanted to continue then it's it's
tagged onto the end of that to a society
which has just seen the end of empire
the end of jim crow and is geared
towards
towards social justice and it is kind it
is it is seeded here right so it's also
a warning to the corporations because
it's permeating the hr departments it's
like don't yes this is going to stay in
the universities and don't be thinking
that you can import two percent of it
without importing the other 98
yeah people leave university and they
join these industries also there's
pressure on corporations
um to comply with the the reigning moral
orthodoxy i mean i don't think that the
average business owner or the average
person in the street knows anything
about foucault or crenshaw or even
thinks much about this but it is in the
air now and it is it is affecting
it is affecting everything and we we do
need to take it seriously without sort
of having a moral panic we need to to
look at it calmly and empirically and
address it as it actually is yeah and
what should we do about it that's the
next issue because
that's another podcast
okay fine that's another point okay so
then the final question for all three of
you is and and maybe one at a time
um
would you do it again
i would yeah i would definitely do it
again um okay so we know that you're an
unrepentant troublemaker i am definitely
in under trouble i've also found like my
one great talent in the world and i feel
like it i've made my own life obsolete
now
okay a wonderful artist if
anybody's looking for one um
but yeah i would definitely do it again
it's worth the risk i think it needed to
be done
helen let's ask you next and then we'll
get let peter have the last word because
he's the one that's got the most on the
line at the moment
yes yes i i would do it again i mean
i've um i i was imagining all sorts of
things from being arrested under sort of
hate speech acts to being physically
attacked because i have an uncommon name
i've had an awful lot of online abuse
i've got some persistent stalkers
but that has essentially i probably
won't get into a phd program in my own
country though somebody in germany has
offered blesser
but yeah it's been um it's been it's
been quite nice
it's been survivable it was worth doing
i would do it again
okay peter
it hasn't begun it had to be done
there's a crisis in the universities
there's a crisis with knowledge
production there's a crisis of
confidence
uh this may can't come at heavy price to
me
and i have had to weigh out my family
obligations helping put my son through
school
you know being a
part of a
marriage so being in a relationship in
which i economically contribute to the
to the house but this had to be done
someone had to do it and if i am a
consequence of this then so be it it had
to be done yeah well peter we're there's
a bunch of us who are not particularly
inclined to let you be a sole
sacrificial victim so if your university
wants to get too stupid with you then um
let's let's assume that they're going to
be consequences i sincerely appreciate
your support from the bottom of my heart
thank you yeah well enough is enough
so well look guys it was really good
talking to you all uh i think that
you're quite the
surreal bunch of troublemakers and
perhaps exactly what this crazy
situation requires and
um
and i hope that i hope peter that that
things work out for you properly over
the next few years it's going to be a
tough haul for a while there's no doubt
about that so are you getting any
student support at your university yeah
i'm getting a lot of student support at
the university but you know i have to be
blunt with you i've if people have
threatened to attack me a few weeks ago
someone spit at me
my colleagues literally will walk down
the corridor they'll turn their heads
it's it's uh but that you know the
uncomfortable things they do that's not
that much different from the typical
university department
yeah
it's it it has seemed to be
i am
i mean i
i want to be blunt with you yeah it is a
concern for my safety in portland when i
leave the house now
yeah and i've now been threatened
on more than one occasion by people
and i'm concerned do you do you do you
find the threats credible i mean i know
every every threat is upsetting but like
are you actually in a situation where
you have some apprehension about leaving
your house
or you ain't grabbing
i don't have any apprehension about
leaving my house uh
look
i you know i wake up in the morning and
i get emails and tweets people telling
me how stupid i am and what a you know
bad person i am and how i'm homophobic
and racist etc that doesn't do anything
to me but when i walk out in the street
i was out of the bar a few weeks ago
or maybe a few months ago i don't even
know mine for timelines but you know
someone
someone came up to me and he started
harassing me as fortunately as with my
jiu jitsu coach john diggins
and
there's a black belt in jiu jitsu and
and he immediately pulled up the chair
beside us and i kept saying let's talk
let's have a conversation no he followed
me in the bathroom i came out of the
bathroom
finally i said look i don't know what's
happening i don't know why you're so
upset but i'm happy to talk to you and
he said i don't want to talk to you
peter i want to hurt you
yeah that's that's pretty that's pretty
serious yeah and then it happened again
on the street when i was surrounded
about a week and a half ago by people
i assume they're anti for people or
something who clearly wanted to
hurt me
so you know i am i am concerned i am
concerned well look look i mean those
for people who haven't been through it's
very hard for people who haven't been
through that sort of thing to understand
just exactly how distressing that kind
of occurrence is not only because it
happens but because it could happen
again and it could become more serious
so i'm really sorry to hear that i
didn't realize it didn't come to that
that's that's no laughing matter
i appreciate that and and threats on
your door left on your door and on any
poster that's got anything to do with
you and there's there's there's
swastikas there's insults there's
leaflets and notices and yeah honestly
that doesn't
campaign that kind of stuff doesn't
bother me it's when it's in the physical
world where i feel
i feel someone
i mean if someone tells you they're
going to hurt you you should take their
words yes definitely when it's that
direct and when it's that in your face
those threats are credible that that's
that's a real that's a real danger so
that's that's well look i'm really sorry
to hear that and i'm i'm also sorry to
hear that you're paying a substant i'm
sorry to hear in general that you're
paying a substantive price for that um
i'm going to do what i can for what
that's worth to try to make sure that
people hear about this and that you're
not in it alone because i think you guys
are like comedians you know your
canaries in the coal mine and whatever
happens to you is going to happen to a
lot of other people if if it's allowed
to happen to you so it can't be allowed
to happen to you that's what it looks
like to me so thank you thank you for
your support yeah all right guys well
look thanks a lot for talking to me all
uh
it was
uh stupidly interesting talking with you
i know that's a hell of a thing to say
but i just can't believe it's come to
this you know it's so ridiculous you
you you can't you couldn't invent this
in a bad piece of fiction
so and
it's it's so sad that that this is the
sort of thing that we have to occupy
ourselves with when there's serious work
to be done
so
all right well happy new year i suppose
hopefully this will be a watershed year
and things will get more intelligent
from here on in again i'm sure hoping
that'll be the case me too thank you all
right ladies and gentlemen thank you
very much for your time and i'll let you
know when this is all coming online okay
great
okay thank you
bye bye